o bom dia gente tá bom dia gente vamos
lá
bom dia gente bom de internet que está
assistindo online também rolar esse aqui
sou eu quero uma coisa rapidinho vocês
ano passado estava com ivan e e aí tava
pra falar aquelas fotos fotografado de
formatura todo mundo ficar forte junto e
tal e aí não o dia que é pra rolar essas
fotos eu ia fazer a primeira aula do
tamo junto desse coletivo que falar eu
vou falar depois
e enfim vai poder participar mas fiquei
muito bravo assim continue até às costas
com um pessoal e e eu cheguei para fazer
a produtora e aí quero ter outro dia
como é que faz a é o menos 300 reais e
pará
eu então tá eu tinha uma idéia de ligar
primeiro aqui
aí eu tinha uma idéia da manhã é
fotógrafa eu tenho um amigo que trabalha
com eventos porque não consigo uma toga
e eu tiro as agentes tiraram as próprias
fotos
então eu peguei um ônibus e foi para a
redenção
então eu queria fazer um ensaio também
diferente algo diferente pra mim então
eu fui conversar com os vizinhos
eu fazia do minhocão que fazer auto
esporte radicais
fui com ela a 17 food da linha e foi
muito legal pra mostrar pra mim que a
gente não precisa tanto esperar os
outros a gente pode fazer algo que a
gente quer e irão haiti ba não vai dar
não sport tenta fazer algo por nós
mesmos
então é isso que vou falar hoje com
vocês que é todo mundo precisa de um vai
fácil e é isso que eu quero explicar
para vocês agora coloquei no facebook
assim vocês quiserem aprender algo
comigo que vocês gostariam de uma galera
colocou como é que eu posso ter os
tampos mais legais trampos de trabalho
cheguei não conhece
após ter coragem de fazer o que eu quero
fazer
como é que eu posso improvisar e
acreditar no que eu como é que eu posso
tirar a idéia do papel
isso é legal porque vem um pouco da
minha trajetória e já começa pelo
próprio nome criativo que minha mãe me
deu meu pai se chama henrique e mesmo
assim vou vou fazer algo diferente para
seguir como é que era e inglês
e aí quando eu vou me inscrever nos
lugares e falou eric país a quem sai
assim sai assim saias nunca saiu eric
que na verdade é assim eu nem vou falar
do meu sobrenome porque né
os lobbies e aí eu fiz uma coisa pra
mostrar pra vocês que eu sempre me
perguntava também na qual é minha
profissão e isso é muito difícil a gente
porque agora eu fui criança no hotel ele
e ela contou com essa profissão
e aí eu fiquei sim e sempre acontece eu
não sei que eu faça o que eu faço muita
coisa e isso é difícil a gente e aí isso
vem muito da ldu a infância e
adolescência que se pergunta o que quer
ser quando crescer e é isso que eu quero
fazer um tempo com vocês hoje também
todo mundo tem coisa pra notar e então
já quero que vocês pensem que vocês
querem ser quando crescer
no final vai ter uma coisa para vocês
fazerem já escreveu aí então pela minha
infância por aí lá na mistura até hoje
mas é mais jovem
o pessoal não gostava eu falava nem
aqueles a que eu tenho pra alma e eu
adorava ir pra aula europa porque estava
saindo de casa estava fazendo coisa
diferente e eu adorava fazer coisas que
a gente não fazia nada porque eu gosto
da coisa com isso que a coca cola do ano
por aí
é muito legal porque tem algo que eu
posso fazer uma experiência e gente era
pré-internet isso aqui é minha fonte de
informação uma banca de jornal
lá a gente podia comprar coisas a voz de
fazer o que a gente gostaria de aprender
então pasmem gente eu tinha um cd a
gente pede
eu tenho ainda então eu não comprei o
que impede a mas eu tinha um cd com ela
e todo o trabalho feito por isso não
contempla o professor
e aí chegou o ensino médio e só chegou
para nós falou olha só eu quero que
vocês agora o foco de vocês vai ser o
enem porque vocês agora tem que sair uma
faculdade que você
vão ser grandes banavar a e eu também
encontra uma coisa esse ano eu não sabia
escolher se queria bolacha salgada ou a
valer bolacha doce no menor no recreio
na merenda já tinha escolherá a
faculdade que eu queria fazer ao seu
lado durante quatro cinco seis anos
gente será difícil e aí eu fiz de graça
pra vocês entendem agora
isso aqui é o tempo de experiência mais
ou menos as coisas que aconteceram
comigo e ali é o meu nível de baixa
poder vai fazer pra quem não conhece é
tipo nível de eu ser muito errado e
assim ao ensino médio técnico já estava
começando e aí eu fui para a
administração porque eu quero que não
sabe o que fazer vai fazer administração
e aí foi muito ruim porque na linha de
agente relativa precisão cara ao vivo
que estava lá em manaus ela já cantava e
aí eu me ver com aquilo que fora e aí eu
fui numa gráfica e minha mãe já me deu
um toque minha mãe sempre criativa a ele
precisando de gente está fazendo meu
copo no meu currículo falei daí de
alguém e foi o primeiro emprego de
carteira assinada e 17 anos assim foi
ali naquela etapa para ele e conseguir
uma amiga minha colocou no meu msn
na verdade e aí fazendo um curso novo
chamado produção multimídia e fui
pesquisar a mídia tinha tudo que eu
sempre quis fazer em apenas dois anos e
meio porque ela falava tinha coisa de
foto vídeo design música
empreendedorismo o web para discutir
todas as coisas que tinha na banca que
eu queria comprar para vender
então eu fui produção multimídia pode
ver que o nível de baixa poder foi
subindo e aí eu parecia assim na na
produção multimídia uma semana acadêmica
e era pra todo mundo fantasiado óbvio
que foram só três pessoas eu era a
terceira e engraçada que é uma pessoa
que está no meio de vocês aí olha pra
mim e pra ela e ela está aí até hoje
vamos lá
hum e aí ela as primeiras aulas lá a
gente viu várias que há coisas novas e
lecionou de criatividade e ele falava
sobre algumas coisas tipo acho tesch no
coletivo que fazem intervenções urbanas
cosmonauta apresentações viradas
perestroika que é uma escola de
atividades criativas ted x que é onde o
pessoal vai se inspirar
a gente é isso eu tenho eu preciso estar
nesse meio eu preciso ir participar de
alguma forma
então eu conseguir a trabalhar tanto
aparecer nos testes como foi não vai
fazer um estoque meu currículo pra eles
fui conversando e tudo que ele falou
assim ah precisamos de uma pessoa para
fazer tal coisa tá aqui
apesar do toque e o ted não foi
diferente
a gente precisa alguém pra fazer sua
aceitação gráfica sabe desenhar óbvio
que nem a não sabia eu aprendi e fui
fazer suas anotações gratz de porto
alegre foi internado e lá apenas para
que se uma coisa que agora isso
aconteceu e eu queria compartilhar tanto
na aula e agora com você também a teoria
do feijão no dente eu aposto que todo
mundo já viu uma pessoa cuidando da
gente viu é um índice de 22 pessoas
aquela pessoa que vai sim e aí aquela
outra pessoa que vai lá chama no canto e
meu só ele está com um dente está e hoje
eu sou essa pessoa que vai lá e fala que
está com feijão no dente e e na vida de
um professor que ele veio de uma outra
faculdade totalmente diferente pessoal é
mais alargado pessoal assim a bota um
vídeo para ver o cara tinha uma baita
experiência e quando chegou na produção
multimídia pessoa
vamos pegar a câmera vamos gravar muitas
coisas a fazer muita coisa e aí ele não
conseguia entender aquilo e quase foi
demitido
então eu tive coragem de chegar pra ele
chega né com ele e falar olha só a droga
e eu falei isso na cara dura pra ele e
e eles me gozem sério e aí eu fui
conversando olha só o tamanho gráfico
assim é que pode fazer dia chamou a
atenção do aluno
então quando começa a falar e mostrar um
monte de coisa só falar falar por alguma
rede social ganha de ti então começa a
fazer coisas que tu mostra coisa que já
fez faz o pessoal faz exercício enfim
mudou tanto aquilo conversa com os
professores também junto com ele o que
ele virou até para limpo da nossa da
minha turma que me formei do tipo foi do
quadro demitido num nível muito grande e
é meu brother longe
isso a gente pode ver vários nomes
também na pressão a que chamamos de
feedback extraordinário e quando fui
falar um monte de pessoas mais velhas e
falei há uma dica valiosa e aí então eu
também consegui achar de chipipa
cosmonauta só deixando então eu queria
muito participar com eles queria muito
fazer algumas atividades então tudo que
óbvio parecia estava tentando junto e
cosmonauta eu achei um grupo de nerds
que nem eu trabalho a gente
a pauta que vão fazer uma coisa de fazer
isso e conta com intervenções urbanas e
tal eu vi que por um lado pro unidos
pela europa o pessoal fazer muito com
este post e de colar e tal fazermos clã
mas a arte tal e aí eu peguei e fui
fazer faculdade
aí eu fui falar com meu orientador lago
o mestre lá ele já faz inédita desculpa
depois e isso mudou minha vida melhor
disse que depois da euforia não deu
muito certo ficou lá um tempo eu me
convidei as pessoas
fiz uma nova arte coloquei de novo a
participar
gente isso aqui é fruto de outras
pessoas lá pra cá a faculdade
gente isso aqui é esse que foi feito
agora os dois meses atrás e isso aqui o
pessoal mesmo nome e tradição todo mundo
que entra tem que fazer o que tem que
vencer outra pessoa uma coisa boa parte
do terceiro que fazer algo diferente
todo mundo para aquele mesmo caminho
vamos fazer um ep
vamos fazer um site e nem quer fazer a
coisa com 10
não quero fazer diferente então vou
criar a própria escola dentro da escola
que me formei
arte feita e aí eu fiz a escola que eu
sempre sonhei então uma pequena escola
que era ensinar coisas que a gente nao é
que a gente não aprende na escola que a
empatia como tirar a idéia do papel e
enfim só que aí que aconteceu eu dei
tanto foco praquela que meu nível na
mesma nota 1
e aí eu fui dispensado então tipo vai lá
só que tive uma conversa muito legal
porque o dunga olhou pra mim e falou eu
quero sair daqui mas saí daqui voltado
para a educação porque têm muito foco
pra isso e é um cara muito bom pra isso
e mesmo sendo dispensado então a eu
continuei coletivo eo coletivo deu muito
certo então a gente fez algumas ações e
por exemplo essa que é o pessoal que lá
em guaíba não tem lixeira então esperar
uma garrafinha e eles mesmos fizeram a
lixeira está no jornal o centro que o
lugar foi muito legal se você não gostar
tirar as lixeiras
não sei porque me sim e aí me formei na
gente então tinha que falar de uma coisa
diferente também e nesta formatura
conheci um cara que fundou a hype que é
o estudo um em sua animação e o carambas
fazem a animação aqui em porto alegre a
fazer o que preciso fazer participar
eu odeio 3d mas eu posso fazer e ajudar
em alguma outra coisa então eu consegui
participar do bate na porta do carro e
falei para o gabriel eu gosto muito de
animação mas sou daqueles caras que fica
olhando os extras do dvd e tal e ver
como é que funciona que faz para
participar e tal e ele me deu um
ultimato pedia que permite boas e vamos
ver o que dá falar nem fundou o núcleo
de criação e fiz um monte de coisa legal
lá tem um desenho rolando hoje que a do
android phone e meu nome nos créditos
gente eu tenho um desenho no crédito às
funções de infância realizado e aí que
aconteceu eu pedi demissão porque porque
a nossa vida mais ou menos assim a gente
tem aquele monte de coisa para fazer e à
tarde na mata em baixa e sem aquele
monte de coisa acumulado a gente não
faça as coisas então eu queria fazer
algo mais pela educação queria fazer
algo mas só quem não tem uma base boa
educação então vou correr atrás então
puxei um pós adolescência puxei uma
difícil
vamos conseguir grátis e comecei a fazer
o as coisas o empreendedorismo a voz
carro começou a fazer há os cursos
algumas coisas vamos também lançar no
mercado ea gente pode aprender com isso
que numa aula quando a gente pergunta
pessoas
olha a gente tem aula disso que vocês
esperam que vocês querem aprender com
isso é muito mais legal a gente prende
aprende muito mais que a gente tem muito
medo de coisas que podem ser muito legal
é muito legal para nós assim que a gente
pode anotar nossas idéias a gente tem
que tirar as idéias do papel esse que
são os quatro cadernos que me acompanhar
durante os dois anos e se ela 80% das
idéias que eu tinha ele conseguindo até
a convencer camiseta fazer cartaz fazer
um total sobre o lego também eu tinha um
pouco de medo de que brincar com legos
que eu tenho chance
e aí houve tipo nada que eu possa fazer
de palestras de pijama também e aí bate
ocorre com as coisas que eu aprendi não
gosto de animação vou compartilhar quais
são as coisas que aprendi trabalhando em
gráfico em agência
vamos fazer um grupo vamos compartilhar
hoje eu tô com esse projeto da amazon
sat que é falar sobre educação falar
sobre empreendedorismo falar sobre
criatividade no modo mais legal porque
eu sei que tem um grupo que fala que a
5% as pessoas ainda querem ser
professores
mas acredito que tem muito mais é que
hoje tem gente assim é que quer
compartilhar o que se quer compartilhar
o que sabe que quer ajudar outras
pessoas
por exemplo se um desafio são exercícios
de exercício em atividade há como é que
como é que será que isso vá contra mão e
aí a minha dica as finais não vá e que
vão ser o tema de casa de vocês e vocês
pensarem o que eu quero ser quando
crescer e por isso ao final de sua
palestra o que vocês notarem e você
deixa um contato e troca em todo o lado
porque vocês agora vão ser responsáveis
pelo sonho de uma outra pessoa e quem
sabe vocês os seus meios do sonho porque
de repente não pode fazer algo legal
então dá mais
do lado e já atuam juntos
a última vez que você ensinou algo pra
alguém né
a gente fica assim muito querendo o seu
reino e tal mas aí a gente faz alguma
coisa que a gente parou pra pensar no
nosso futuro no futuro de emprego no
futuro disputar o que eu quero ser que
eu quero fazer o quê
ajudar o mundo em especial entusiasmo
tomar drogas a gente pode mudar as
coisas
quando foi a última vez que a gente fez
algo pela primeira vez e isso que estou
fazendo hoje é uma coisa incrível eu
sonhava muito com isso e então gente é
essa a minha mensagem para vocês
contem comigo por que precisar e não
esqueçam vai lá e faz
obrigado